pas traître
voir comme ça c'est pas mal par contre
peyrens de partout
partout ici je parviens pas belle mais
non se rendant ce serait mieux un ouais
mais on fera tout seul on on n'aura plus
ces derniers devront voir comme ça
on est pas mal de bière de vol
je
c'est fait
voilà on peut peut-être la longe
bonsoir
c'est vrai que nature
on a mangé les ondes à manger notre pain
plan tombe et laisse tomber les story
ever d'eau
quatre arrivées ni pleurer
ap
on la dit quand tu as écrit par thomas
cook un petit commentaire à la hulot en
train de travailler sur laika l'artois
paul white ra et voilà qu'on soit un peu
plus notre du doigt à vendre une
question autour de moi parce que je te
rappelle qui a le sens du doigt
voilà des bords michèle laget tout ni
moins et ben voilà le supplément du smim
devant voter c'est pourquoi mme hervieux
comme ça non c'est pas pour ça qu'elle
avait un trou dans la carte